in the first round of italy's
presidential election the overwhelming
majority of ballots cast were left blank
[Music]
at this moment we don't have a candidate
who can get enough votes to win outright
if we were to announce a candidate now
we would burn their chances of winning
by voting blank is a way for everyone to
maintain a certain neutrality and wait
until enough parties converge on one
candidate
the presidential election almost always
lasts several rounds as voters members
of parliament and regional
representatives float names of various
candidates until they decide on one
just two days before the vote former
prime minister silvio berlusconi
withdrew from the race making the
current prime minister mario draghi the
front-runner
but the largest block of voters a
right-wing coalition is opposed to
draghi's candidacy
the concern for many voters if draghi
ascends to the presidency is the
government will collapse putting the
pandemic recovery at risk
also putting many current members of
parliament out of work as the political
tide has shifted since the last election
in the search for stability voters are
even considering the current president
sergio matarella although he says he's
not interested in continuing
the presidency is a largely ceremonial
role in italy but as head of state the
president weighs in to resolve political
crises at times even naming a new prime
minister with parliamentary support
there's little surprise that no
candidate was able to win enough votes
here on monday in rome because according
to italy's constitution during the first
three rounds of voting a two-thirds
majority is required to win and
subsequent rounds that's reduced to a
simple majority
all signs point to this election
carrying on for many more days as
political parties try to find a
consensus candidate who can win enough
votes
adam marini al jazeera rome